hello again I realized when I started
thinking about doing a book a month that
it was going to take me a very long time
to get through all my favorite books so
I thought maybe I might do the
occasional single book but there's also
the idea of looking at themes so it's
new year so this month's theme is forest
gardening and it's you could think of
forest gardening as being something
that's more to do with the summer
because of course it's when you might be
harvesting from the garden through the
spring the summer in the autumn but the
winter is when we do planning and also
when we might be planting a lot of
things in the forest garden so perhaps
you've heard of forest gardens or
perhaps you already have one but if you
start looking at the books on forest
gardening those that have the words
forest gardens in the title there's
quite a lot of them and so this really
is just looking at what are the
different books that you might come
across and why might there be the book
for you so I'm gonna start with the
first book on forest gardening now it's
important to say that forest garden is
modeled originally on the tropical food
forest where a lot of food is grown
below the canopy of the forest because
there's a lot of light in the tropics
and you can grow things at ground level
under trees now in Britain and similar
latitudes Northern Europe and so on it's
a rather different situation is a lot
less light here so it has to be quite
dark underneath forest canopy and so
really a forest garden shouldn't really
be so much called a forest garden Martin
Crawford who's one of the most
inspirational people doing forest
gardening these days he says really he
would prefer the term woodland edge
gardening because it's really looking at
what grows on the woodland edge all the
different levels and so on anyway so
there the first book was called forest
gardening and so essentially that that
name has been kept
and it was written by Robert Hart who
was I was very lucky to go and stay with
for a but a whole week in the last year
of his life and I remember looking at
the visitor book and seeing how many
people have visited his tiny little
quarter acre forest garden which always
felt much bigger than the quarter acre
when you were in it and how many people
have been inspired and of course the
evidence of that is seen in the forest
gardens that you find around these days
but also the number of books that we
have now with the words forest gardening
in the title so Robert really was
talking about his journey the creation
the forest garden but there wasn't a lot
of technical detail there were some
plants in here and so on but he didn't
have a lot of technical detail in here
to help you create your own if you like
so so that's the first one
so Patrick Whitefield who's who was a
very inspirational permaculture teacher
and had written a number of books very
important books so he spent time with
Robert and essentially wrote the
technical manual that Robert never got
to write so this book was quite fun
trying to hold up a book and share it
you see it's got quite a lot of there's
some nice photo photos in here and well
Roberts forest garden quite a lot of
Roberts folks garden here things about
the different layers of the forest
garden the things that you might be
planting and so on there's also a bit at
the beginning about how you might lay
out the garden different patterns in the
garden
[Applause]
hmm we are gonna find the things and
that the kind of basics of what
permaculture what box Gardens are and
how they work and so on just never find
the diagram you need anyway so that's
the technical manual the first technical
manual really on forest gardening around
that time also a couple cord adi and ken
fern were experimenting with growing
many different plants that might be
well-suited to the forest garden and
they wrote this book plants for a future
and set up a charity also with the same
name and they've also created over the
years many years now a large database of
plants that you can access at plants for
a future
I think it's P faf dog on the internet
with over 8,000 different species now
that they've documented lots of details
about how to grow them cultivate them
what kind of conditions they like what
they produce and so on and this book
really is there it's kind of the
highlights or the main the main
attractions if you like there's got some
nice color photographs in here I
remember when I got this book I was
incredibly inspired to go out and get
the seeds of many of these things and
grow them and some more successfully
than others but again really excellent
book plans for future and then across
the pond in the States these two books
came out so see now we've changed scale
entirely so these two books edible
forest Gardens Gardens volumes one and
two different thicknesses same price the
reason is that this is got color in it
and this is just black and white
but both excellent books on different
aspects so volume one is vision and
theory and volume to design and practice
this give you a sense of what's going on
inside the books again very lovely books
lots of information lots of research
lots of case studies and so this is a
case study of robert's garden Robert
Hart's garden Winlock edge and the
things that were good about it and the
things that didn't work so well and
that's one of the key things about this
book is it's looking at what what are
the successful strategies and one of the
things that are not so good what have we
learned from doing these different
things and forest gardens are designed
to be multifunctional so primarily
perennial focused although they might
have some readily self-seeding annuals
in the system and that the outputs from
the garden would include quite a lot of
food but not necessarily just food so
you have many plants in there to support
other plants or to provide other things
and one of the nice things about the
parts for a future book this one here it
has some in your pen disease list sort
of find it uses there we are right at
the back and there's got all kinds of
things in here gelatine substitutes oil
egg substitutes condiments coffee
substitutes that might be some people
might wait weather is really a
substitute for coffee and seed pods this
fire retardants theory and non-edible
uses there's lots of things in here
adhesives and beads and eggs and
insecticides and all kinds of things so
plants for many many uses
so these two books are great they all
set you back certainly outside the US
quite a few pounds or euros and probably
dollars do they say they don't have the
price on the back in dollars oh yes they
do $75 still quite a lot of money but if
you're thinking of doing price gardening
seriously then they're essential really
because they're great books and the
money you spend on the books you'll save
anyway the mistakes you don't make the
trees you don't kill by putting them in
the wrong place
so kind of coming back and sitting
somewhere in between the brevis scales
is Martin Crawford's first kind of
proper big book he's written many what
might be called kind of directories of
different plants around different
categories trees and shrubs and ground
covers and nitrogen fixers and all kinds
of things lots of technical stuff this
was his first kind of pretty book if you
like and you can see my copy is fairly
well tape together from many years of
abuse and it's not bad at all the book
but compared to the price of the other
books you know this this is the book
that has plenty in it it's full-color
it's very beautiful work there's lots of
technical detail in it it's basically
Martin's experience from all the many 20
odd years of him doing forest gardening
what he's learned the things he's
growing the things that work to some
degree the plants that he's grown that
are in the plants for a future book that
he agrees with rather than thinking a
bit borderline whether I would eat that
or not
and so there's all the details of how to
put it together and then the long lists
of species and the kind of conditions
they need and what they produce and how
you look after them
and so on and so forth so an excellent
book certainly in terms of value for
money I think this is about 30 pounds
which for the side of the book and what
you get is really a bargain and I think
you were thinking of starting with the
forest garden to do it properly that's
where I would recommend starting that
one and then there's a few books here
that kind of sit to the side of the
other books there's food from your
forest garden this was Martin and a
friend of mine Caroline akin who is
another permaculture teacher and Marta's
she'd live quite close together so
Martin gave her she kept giving her
produce from the garden and she went
about seeing what they could do with it
so it's really a collection of recipes
around how to use the different things
that come from the forest garden because
whilst forest gardens should include a
lot of things we likely like apples and
pears and soft fruits and so on there's
also a lot of things that we can grow in
a forest garden which are less familiar
and it's good to know how to use them so
this is a book of plants and recipes if
you'd like again really nice lovely book
highly recommended food from your forest
garden and this is the one that I'm
obsessed by at the moment the forest
garden greenhouse because living in cold
temperate Britain and I'm very excited
by what could be grown more inside a
greenhouse environment in terms of
things that we can't normally grow here
what's on the edge of and wherever you
are there's always it's likely that
there are things you can't grow either
because it's too hot to it's too cold
and so Jerome who wrote this book the
forest garden green house lives a quite
high altitude in Colorado and they grow
bananas and papayas and things in the
greenhouse environment because they
create very what they call a climate
battery which is a way of storing the
heat
the warm time of the year and during the
day into the soil which involves quite a
bit of construction but it all together
some pictures if going on in the book
the case studies all of the different
greenhouses that they have and how
they're designed to do to create
different environmental conditions you
feel like tropical or Mediterranean this
is the basic idea is that a fan brings
the heat from the top of the greenhouse
down into a collection of pipes which
are buried in the ground there we are
there's quite a lot of work to do the
begin with you've seen quite a lot of
pipes but once you've got that in place
then essentially you create the
conditions to grow lots of interesting
things in a greenhouse and situation
obviously not really something that
works in a real greenhouse but they say
anything from 10 meters by three and a
half four meters upwards and you should
be good and all being well we have one
of those very same a couple more books
one is forest gardening in practice this
is by Thomas Romeo Tzu again there's
another permaculturist in the UK Network
and he's gone around basically looking
at existing forest gardens studying how
they work and so some of them are
private some of them are community one
of the things that work about forest
gardens so just very difficult to show a
book of this size to the camera and do
the logistics of holding it and so on
but so essentially it's his research
journey if you like of going around all
these different projects what they've
learned what's good what's not so good
how to do forest gardening even better
than we have up to now
very recent book very very again very
useful particularly if you're thinking
about creating a forest garden what
might go wrong this also mean what can
you do well so the last book is quite
thin as you can see but literally
arrived yesterday and it's a little bit
played on forest gardening a beginner's
guide by Graham Burnett now Graham is
the author of a number of different
smallish booklets and also a rather
chunky book called the vegan book of
permaculture which is here somewhere
here it is and probably best known for
writing permaculture a beginner's guide
which is now gone to a color version
this is also a color booklet and full
color throughout it's full of grams
great of the diagrams color diagrams I
think it's quite fitting there Graham
should write a beginner's guide to
forest garden because as you can see
none of these have beginners guides
they're all rather big books it's very
tempting to write a lot about forest
gardening and but very fitting because
often if you go on to the internet and
you type in forest gardening you'll get
pictures and you'll often see this
diagram essentially which Graham drew
many years ago in for that particular
beginners guide so it's nice to see him
actually pre creating beginner's guide
to forest gardening and yes it's quite
small it's got 20 about 30 pages but he
does he makes really good use of the
space so he starts with a very kind of
succinct description of what forest
gardening is and how it's important for
what the environment and so on so you
have lost the page already different
functions education health and
well-being and so on a little bit of a
history as picture of Robert Hart there
and then you start getting into the
realm of how do I go about doing it for
myself
so what do you want I mean a forest
garden is a structure really and what
you put into that structure is really
down to what your needs are
and so he just kind of asked the key
questions of what do you want what do
you go Lots what's your current
situation what scale can you work out
because we can even create a forest
garden in a very small garden very small
space we just you know a single tree and
collection of things around and then he
began provides a nice little pattern
about how you might create it over time
and just got things about resources and
stock designing the ground layer look on
mapping plan there that's c1 so forth
good bad B's and then he gets into some
recommended plants and I particularly
like one of my favorite plants is
Japanese wine very fantastic fruit it
grows very well in the forest garden and
so it's quite succinctly a really
excellent book booklet to buy for
someone as a gift or just as a starter
it's really about inspiring giving kind
of the essence of what forest gardening
is about and where to start what are the
key things to know about so my table is
down there's a lot of books there
hopefully there's one there that it's
perfect for you or fee to give to
somebody as a gift and I wish you a lot
of fun dreaming up what you're going to
plant